this fascinating creature as the Chinese
woman cooks her food cleaning the dishes
she follows a disciplinary rules that
her family taught her when she was
younger
hey guys I'm here with Lauren
gah we just went to the beach it was
awesome I know you guys don't know her
boyfriend but IIIi think her and I would
be better than her and whatever this
name is well he's an unknown who the
[ __ ] cares about him what does your
boyfriend do for a living
even accountant Wow what a fascinating
career this man is leading write a
really interesting career path that he's
chosen to go on yeah very safe and
secure that's uh it's just the life the
lead risk-taker we're talking about here
I hope he watches this video so I can
battle him one day as you can see behind
me why I look like God right now because
we were gonna do you know watch a few
trailers I was so focused on getting the
battery charger
I forgot the actual battery I said you
know what I want to do though I just I
just want to get to know you better
Lauren so this is a new show I'm calling
getting to know dot-dot-dot
and today's first episode no it's not
you know even in baggy sweat sore ass
though it looks good what would you say
is your number one dream date car sad
are what we would do what would you what
would you do she has archery skills
combined cooking and the skills of
Legolas say Lauren yes do you have a
certain particular theme
I was raised Christian
I am not necessarily that religious
would you consider yourself still a
Christian I like watching Lauren do this
it reminds me of all the fantasies I
have about our future together ROM just
watching her cook and I'm going wow my
beautiful wife's serving me food like
the woman should don't do kung fu on me
okay people we're gonna see Laurens
giant mansion she lives it's a mansion
so this is the front of her place there
is a giant room that you could see
through oh there's a shoe show this is
Shane he's an engineer gets a lot of
Pattani
I'm gonna do a 360 right now
this is Lauren's view she gets to look
at all this there are people swimming
down there now they just left be like a
voyeur a voyeur I'm sorry well it makes
me feel really uncomfortable right now
is this erection I have it's kind of
just making me feel very awkward and I
think you got to cut it out before I do
something your response this is not
going down the path of humor I wanted it
to do
can't stand rape jokes okay so you're
ready to show the viewers your bikini
are you ready fine whatever Lauren won't
let me see her messy bedroom here we go
Wow Lauren where is your Asian Asst
you're supposed to be clean and tidy I
don't know what that is
he's her gay friend Milton we have to
know he's gay he's really good-looking
you look good in that photo good job
this is Lauren as a cheerleader she's a
sexy cheerleader this is Lauren tripping
out on some LSD I totally saw Lauren in
a bikini and Wow Holy Mother of God
that was awesome ha ha
see I threw that in there she's fit skin
color is not as tan as you might think
it is that's so hot yeah yeah that's the
closest I've ever been to a woman before
that was awesome yeah let's go check out
her bathroom this is where Lauren does
things that I don't want her to ever let
me know she's doing this is her shower
where I've had many fantasies about
there's multiple mirrors because in case
she has to turn her head to the right
she can look right here what's this is
it some time a Chinese thing what do you
like about this guy
we have fun together only we can joke
around you can talk about weird stuff
nice that's when you know you got
someone special I can be all those
things Lauren why does Daniel get to win
all the time I always lose to Daniel
whatever Lauren whatever Wow dude that's
a lot of [ __ ] shoes you can laugh
together oh we're still talking about
the boyfriend thing he's cute
what's his ethnicity Columbian off [ __ ]
his dick is probably 10 times bigger
than mine or Daniel okay it's lowered
you got to go lower okay nevermind you
can juggle can you juggle something for
us she's gonna juggle for us there we go
oh snap oh damn he actually got mad
because he was here the other day and he
saw that it was still in the box if I
were to look at your resume Lauren what
will be your special skills
cheerleading nice nice but you got a lot
of dick back when your eyes look like a
cat right now it's scary hey dude that
was rather authentic okay it's a good
position
yeah de vivre done one yet but we got
the upper address and that's what counts
people you do make a meow sound because
your eyes look like cat right yeah
hahahaha well I'm gonna turn off the
camera now but I like having footage of
Lauren that I'm saying I'm gonna post on
YouTube but sure whatever it's just for
my personal usage